107 91.
mazar 1-1 so far this year on the second
night of back-to-backs they won the
season series dallas did against memphis
last year two games to one pointed at
luca made in memphis and this is the
first of four match-ups this year
[Applause]
[Music]
they lead the league in blocks
there's a weird set of statistics to be
30th and defensive rating that's so good
and steals and blocks loose ball is
picked up by dallas and reggie bola
cashes in on the second chance
opportunity i don't
think i would expect to hear very often
little and screen from steven adams
[Music]
penetration by finney smith and the lead
for beaumont who jams one year they were
number one in defensive radio they had a
year where they were number two and did
defensive break
they did that respect for the game as
well as the eight nothing dallas run
comes to an end on the anthony melted
three ups up
i heard steph curry say defense travels
but how many times we heard our man harp
say that
here's milton wow off the glass and in
for the anthony melton in transition
very physical player
hey
offense and certainly
will battle on defense as tillman scores
in the pan
rooks
timeout dallas after the dylan brooks
three-pointer he had 20 in the game last
year against the foot
jones just missed the shot
sterling brown splits through the
defense pulls up and hits
deflection by brown
jackson regained possession of the ball
puts it down and finishes difficult
finish that's a skill big guy that's a
skilled play
[Music]
and now the last piece of the puzzle for
him harp is staying healthy
that's a pull-up by jalen brunson he's
had his injury
does his job well
career eight rebounds a game this season
eight rebounds the game
and he will go up and score through
contact off a pass with destiny
biggest lead of the game now for the
grizzlies
powell screen for brunson a couple of
baskets in a row made by jayla brunson
melted a little shake and make trimmer
this is the steven adams and it was no
call for a travel or anything else
just to score by santiago
that's a low number to beat this deep
into the second quarter
vinnie smith organized for a three that
is
working long time coming
[Music]
[Applause]
traded to the last pick of the 2020
first round to select him after playing
hard away first basket
street music for tim hardaway jr scoring
wise
[Music]
[Applause]
brooks has stayed on the floor
just like benny smith did for dallas and
that's what desmond bane does
and trail by 13 points with 223 he left
before the interval
match up a little bit zone wise
jones is so good at that shot that
little floater
three threes have gone down the well for
vinnie smith
[Music]
working for his third three of the game
and give it to him
but the prior game he went 5-9 on three
and scored 23 points against toronto his
second best scoring night of the year
even ahead wow hardaway
rising over jared jackson jr
and christops porzingis missing a second
straight game with a left knee contusion
a post has been scored by jaron jackson
jr
powell
with points for dallas his first basket
of the game
the last
[Music]
way to defensive team in the league
pass
steven adams that's after bullock miss
brooks goes to ground made the shots and
their lead now swelling to 16 points
[Music]
on automatic right now
feet and his body ready to shoot the
basketball
let's play
finish gowdy goes hard to the floor with
a foul on memphis
pocket pass to steven adams
and adam just rumbles inside and scores
dylan brooks
too much on that three-pointer
and they did get the stop but the ball
ends up bouncing favorably for steven
adams who goes out to desmond bane for a
three
refrigerators for his workout absolutely
and they're full by the way when he does
that
there's that floater by tyus jones we've
seen it three different times tonight
let's do this
maybe timmy's going to get that going
put back again after the miss by dylan
brooks
can't have dna and can't have a culture
that could span across eras and remember
britain grind was one way that's in his
plays but now all of these young new
fresh faces have come in
forced him to move it along to steven
adams if you don't do this then the game
just plays out right trying to do
something
oh
[Applause]
jackson
dylan brooks through contact puts up a
shot and scores that's just a tough darn
shot that time by brooks
to make a run against this grizzly
hey
a couple of maverick starters at
tonight's game have returned reggie
bullock maxi cleveland and brunson reads
his own mess and
scores making
[Applause]
and now reggie's got the unenviable task
of trying to guard destiny bane is the
leading scorer tonight for memphis he's
got 20 points put up by dylan brooks
yeah good contest for maxie
tim hart away a three-pointer yes sir
gotta keep shooting and nine is now the
number he throw a line to make it 23.
not a good turn over there and
just attack attack attack
that's got to be a pull down
drove
and drew a foul and made the free throws
and then runs it throws the ball away
and it's a gliding layup smoothly
finished by desmond mayne with a foul
based off what he's doing tonight
[Applause]
gonna pull his scoring at it
16 points a game his heart away drains
at three from out front
yeah tillman hit three throws and bane a
three-point play to swing things back in
the other direction
memphis had another backbreaker it feels
like as adams tips home a missed by
desert
five minutes left
[Music]
[Applause]
he does give you and dallas the much
needed three with 320 left in the game
to make it 88-81
season high and scoring that timeout
proved valuable
dallas kept the ball they scored out of
the timeout there's desmond bane with a
giant killer
again a score
down under three minutes left
[Applause]
it opens up for the last second bronson
able to fight his way all the way to the
basket and score
[Music]
second straight time down the floor to
score he'll get you one when you need
one that's for sure
ruxin had seven in the fourth quarter
hardaway at 17.
the only other fourth quarter points for
the mavs have been cleveland with three
but desmond bane continues to pour in
points
and not only a season high but a career
[Applause]
drives in and scores that that's one of
his favorite shots
he picked an opportunity to use it also
[Applause]
[Music]
air ball three oh it falls for vinnie
smith
left that may have been blocked a little
bit by dylan brooks
desmond baine not only a career-high 29
points also a career-high nine rebounds
and the memphis grizzlies have four
strength wins they haven't trailed at
all in any of those four games the final
tonight heart grizzlies 97 mavericks 90.